if you want to follow along you can pip
install dat aspire that's the library
we're going to be using if you've
installed it already but haven't
upgraded in the past day go ahead and
upgrade it because I put some changes
that will affect this talk I'm a damage
or a data scientist at the next big
sound team at Pandora and oh I forgot to
say if you want to follow along with
this notebook here's a link to it you
can either just follow along through
your web browser or download it and open
it up an I Python notebook all of the
examples that I'm doing can't really be
run from my Python notebook so it
doesn't really matter if you just look
at it in your browser so I'm talking
about building simple data-driven web
applications this whole talk is going to
be about the spire library there's a few
other options
boquete has great tools for doing very
similar things
the spire is a library that I built so I
actually know a little bit about it
so that's what I'll be talking about it
was inspired by a similar library for
are called shiny so that's been around
for a few years and when I started this
project there were less options for
doing the stuff in Python so that was
the motivation for doing this so it's it
doesn't have very many dependencies
cherry pie is what it's using to
actually serve up your web app Jinja 2
is doing some templating stuff and then
all the data stuff is matplotlib for
your plots and pandas and so matplotlib
and pandas can be kind of a pain to
install so hopefully everybody's used
anaconda to take care of those
dependencies and if you have then pip
installed at aspire should work just
fine for installing everything else so
let's get started there's going to be a
very example driven sorry go ahead
I can't hear you
oh yeah sorry seriously it's it's PI
data 2015 underscore spire
okay so this is gonna be a very example
driven talk obvious do it just doing
some live coding and kind of loading
some some of these apps real-time can
everybody see my text editor over here
can make a little bit bigger if that's
if you can't see it raise your hand let
me know I'll bump up the size a little
bit more okay so let's just start with a
simple example your import is always
going to be from spire and port server
that server has an app class so if we
create an instance of that app class it
has a launch method that we can call and
if we run this oh geez that's loud
it launches the server it tells us where
it's being served from right now it's
just serving a locally and if we put
that in our browser then we have an app
there's nothing in it yet we'll add that
in a second in general you'll want to
create your own app class so let's do
that I'll call it simple app and it's
going to inherit the server app so we
need to override a few of the attributes
and methods for the server app we'll get
to those one at a time we'll just start
by giving it a title now we save that
and refresh
we need to create an instance of our app
so now this is an instance of our app
and it has the title that we've given it
so let's give it a few more things
we'll start by giving it some inputs so
the inputs is going to be a list of
dictionaries the dictionary is going to
define the attribute for each of the
inputs so we'll start with just one
input
it'll be type text or a text box and it
needs a key so we'll just call it words
so if we wrote reload we have a text box
now we can give it to find a few more
attributes give it a label
and a default value
okay so let's move on and add some
outputs the outputs come in two parts
well first need to define the the
attributes of the output by defining an
outputs dictionary just like we did with
the inputs or a list of outputs
dictionaries and so we're going to start
with just an HTML output and then each
of our outputs needs an ID
so we reload now we have an HTML output
we haven't defined the the content of
this output yet by default it tells us
that in order to define some content we
need to override the get HTML method so
we'll do that
and this takes one parameter when one
variable called params frames is how the
the inputs talk to the outputs so the
outputs are going to get the values that
they need to generate their content from
the inputs through this params params is
the dictionary keyed by whatever key we
specify in the input dictionary so for
instance to get the words that we put on
a textbox we just get it from the params
dictionary each of the different output
types and the corresponding methods
expect a different return type for a
good HTML we're just going to return a
string
okay now if we reload our app our output
is getting the value from our input and
using that to display the HTML this is
HTML so we can also add some HTML tags
okay we're not quite done this is a
still a static page we can change the
input but it does nothing to update the
output and that's because the output
doesn't know when it's supposed to
update so there are two ways we can tell
the output when it's supposed to update
we can add a control such that when the
control is triggered it tells the output
a check for new inputs an update and
we'll look at that approach first
so controls like outputs and inputs are
just lists of dictionaries we'll just
make a button and this needs an ID as
well I'll call it button 1 and it needs
a label
so we reload this we've got a button it
doesn't do anything yet
because we haven't connected just to the
output so in order to do that we need
the output to reference the control that
should trigger its update so we define
the control ID attribute and just make
it match the idea of whatever control we
want to link it to okay and now if we
update our input and press the button it
updates our output the other way you can
update outputs is directly from the
inputs so this is a pretty simple app
it's a little bit overkill to have a
button let's just have it so that when
we change the state of the input it
changes it updates the output we can do
that through the inputs action ID
attribute which can actually reference
either an output or control so the
action ID here is going to point to the
single output which has ID HTML
I'll leave that there
all right and now if we update the state
of the input and press ENTER then it
updates the output so just two different
ways to accomplish the same thing and
they have different benefits depending
on what your app looks like so in this
case it's a simple app just changing the
input it's fine
for updating the output if you have a
more complicated app where it takes a
long time to load your your data for
your output for instance maybe you want
to wait until you have all of your
inputs set before you start the loading
process so in that case what button
might make some more sense with with a
text box the the change in state is
actually triggered by pressing enter
within the text box other input types
like a slider for instance
we'll just that gets triggered whenever
you change the state of the input so
that's going to be true with like
drop-down menus and checkboxes change in
the state of the output of the input
triggers whatever's pointed out with the
action ID
okay let's just reference this notebook
I've got a few diagrams that kind of
show the relationship between all these
elements so in our first example when we
had inputs outputs and controls the
control ID is referenced by the control
ID of the output and then the outputs
parameters are just pulled from the key
or from whatever the value is of the
inputs keyed by the key attribute and
then when we took out that control we
referenced the output directly from the
action ID of the input so this is a very
simple example but it has all the the
basic components of any spy app you
build it has inputs and outputs it's got
the methods that you used to generate
the actual output and then it has
controls as well if you want to add
those let's look at a slightly more
interesting example let's suppose that
you wrote a function to go out on the
internet and collect some stock data and
put that into a panda's data frame okay
so this this method takes a dictionary
called params as a key ticker and then
the value is what it's going to use to
actually determine which stock to go get
so in this case we're going to go get
stock data from Microsoft so we've run
that we get a panda's data frame with
closed high-low and open prices if we
were to changes to something else look
at data for that particular company so
we want to put this into a spire a p' so
we're going to start with a text input
we'll key it off of the ticker label it
with
ticker symbol and then the starting
value vmss to you and then we'll start
with just a table output so the table or
the output type will be table we'll just
give it the ID table and we'll just for
now keep the control button to trigger
the the update of that output okay if we
were to just save this and reload the
inputs as expected the output tells us
that we need to override the get data
method to generate our table so
conveniently the function that we
created to go get this data is already
called good data so we can almost copy
and paste this over here
and then we need to make sure we include
all of our imports
all right and now if we reload this we
get a table with all the data we pulls
from the web
we can change the input and that changes
the data so this is returning a panda's
data frame and one of the really really
great things about pandas data frames my
favorite feature is that it's super easy
to create visualizations directly from
the data frame each data frame has a
plot method that you just call and it
generates a plot I'll show you how that
works
here if you haven't seen it before this
is the data frame that we created up
here just by pulling that stock data and
if we call the plot method on it it just
plots the data it's so simple so we're
going to take advantage of this and add
a plot to our web app so we need to
define another dictionary for the new
output type this is going to be type
plot
we'll give it an ID the one on the right
yeah that's this is the the ipython
notebook that I reference at the
beginning of the talk yeah I'll go back
to the link one more time
this bitly link it goes to that ipython
notebook I just leave it up for now okay
and then we wanted to update whenever we
press that button so we'll give it the
control ID button one I'll refresh our
app and we have a plot you may be
thinking what doesn't plot have a method
that we need to override and the answer
is yes it does it has a gift plot method
but the default method for server app
says look for a get plot method if it's
not there then look for a good data
method get a data frame from that method
and then call the plot method on that
data frame and return that so if we
wanted to do something different like
maybe we wanted to actually have date as
the x-axis here we could we could do
that we could just add to get plot
method
and then we'll take advantage of the
fact that we've already written a method
to get the data
and then we could just return
this was basically what's happening if
you don't do anything by default if you
don't define a get block method we're
just going to set the index to date
so if you set an index for a data frame
then the plot method will use that index
as the x-axis for your plot so you could
also in the same way you could have this
as an object and I think it has a set
title method up here we we defined the
company name that was part of what we
got back from the API we were hitting so
we I think we can just do that to add a
title to this
you know
so I'll cheat a little bit and see what
I actually did
oh I actually have to return this
there we go so you could do the same
thing by adding labels for your axes and
setting all types of attributes for that
plot object the plot object is actually
like I think it's a map plot libbed axes
object so you can either have your can't
plot method return that or a plot figure
object a map public platform so
whichever one of those is more
convenient for you it's just a map plot
live object I'll get to that in a second
yeah
towards the end of the talk I'll talk
about how to do multiple outputs of the
same type
let's also spice things up a little bit
and use a drop-down input all of this
stuff can stay the same but a drop-down
has options so we need to define an
options dictionary so the dictionary
here is going to be a list of it's a
list of dictionaries one for each option
and they need to have label
and of value and the value is what
actually gets passed to the whatever
method is using this this thing
okay let's add a few more of these
all right so we change the input and we
get a new output so we could actually
have still have the input update the
outputs directly the input only has one
action ID so we can't reference both of
the outputs directly from the input but
we can't reference the button so we can
have the input reference to the button
and then when you change the state of
the input it's as if you're pressing the
button so if we added an action ID here
and how to point to our button control
now changing this input is equivalent to
pressing the button by having the button
is pointless now you never need to press
it so we can actually use the control
type hidden' you still need a control to
to change multiple outputs with a single
input but you don't actually need
physical control alright and finally the
outputs can get a little bit cluttered
here if you if you have more than one
especially if you have more than two so
we can organize a little bit by adding
tabs so tabs is just going to be another
list in this case is actually just a
list of strings the the title of the
tabs so we'll have a tab for a plot and
another tab for our table and then we
just need to tell to specify in the
output dictionary what tab each of these
should go into
great so now we have a tab for a plot
and another tab for our table
so a diagram to show how this slightly
more complicated situation works you've
got an input that references control and
that control is being referenced by two
different outputs and then if you had
multiple inputs let's say you had 20
inputs all of those input values would
be passed to all of your plots so you
don't have to worry about specifying
which input to apply all the plots got
all of the input values and again those
are passed through with this params
dictionary so there's a few more things
you can try let's add let's try another
output type for a dictionary for
download type is download ID we'll just
call it download and we're actually will
add another button for this this
particular action and it doesn't need to
go in a table or in a tab
so let's add a second button for our
download action
okay
but default all of these outputs will
load when the page loads so you see that
as soon as I loaded this page I
downloaded whatever it was I was
downloading we usually don't want that
behavior with downloads so we can
specify another attribute called
on page load and set that equal to false
all right and now when we load this page
we have a download button and when we
press it we get a CSV we open this
that's just the content of our data
frame so just like we saw with the the
plot we don't need to specify an output
for the download output it will just by
default pull whatever data if we're
getting from good data if we wanted to
alter that data before we passed it to
to the download we could do that by
overriding the get download method but
that's not necessary if you just want to
download whatever is being passed from
get data okay
also these tables are can be sortable
you just need to specify in the
dictionary that you want it to be sort
of wool so there's a sortable key and we
can just set it to true
so now we can sort this table by all of
its fields
I'll mention that the I'm not going to
do a demo for this but there's a couple
of great javascript based Python
plotting libraries ok is my favorite
vincent's another good one we have to
get HTML method we have the HTML output
both of those libraries can output HTML
static HTML that you can use to generate
JavaScript based visualization so if we
go back up to one of these live examples
we've got we'll look at this one
this is what we just a version of what
we just generated but this also has a
bouquet plot and so if you haven't used
bouquet before it's awesome its
interactive you can scroll and zoom so
it's a great plotting library and you
can integrate this directly into your
spire app okay
Oh also in this example we can link our
inputs such that when we make a change
to one input it will be reflected in
another input so for instance if we
change let's say we we had a stock
that's not in this list so Microsoft
isn't in this list and we wanted to give
our users the ability to specify one of
another company we could do that and
that changes the company drop-down menu
so that it isn't confusing that it still
says Google when actually we're looking
at Microsoft data or if you were to
select Google it changes the value there
so those are just a kind of a few extra
features of Speyer it's it's fairly
straightforward to to deploy a spire app
so that somebody that's not looking at
your computer can see it Heroku and
Python anywhere option offer free
options for that and I have a blog post
on how to set that up with Heroku
digitalocean is a great option too they
have plans for five dollars a month and
in fact this app is being hosted on not
this one
this app is being hosted on digitalocean
this is another app that uses the
bouquet plotting library so it has the
ability to kind of zoom in but it also
has tooltips which is great and then you
can also host on AWS which is like about
$10 a month if you have no traffic
coming to your site but who knows so
yeah there's a there are other input
types other output types the best way I
think to figure out how to use all of
this is just to look at the examples
which is a number of examples in the
github repo hopefully the documentation
will will beat that up a little bit soon
to talk about all the different things
you can do yeah oh and somebody asked
about what happens if you have multiple
outputs of the same type so let's say we
wanted to add another plot we'll just
copy and paste this one
so tight plot it needs to have a unique
ID so we'll call it plot B and we'll put
it in the same tab so if we were to up
update this we've got two plots now but
they're both using the same get plot
method so the workaround here is you can
actually rather than overriding one of
the built-in methods from the the server
app class you can also use the you can
name your your method whatever your ID
is so if I were to call my second plot
method plot B that's the ID for the
second plot
it takes the same values and will have
it generate the same thing for the
different title
oh well we actually have to do is we
have to we can't use the get plot method
and the the custom naming method we have
to name both of our plots using the IDs
okay so now we get two distinct plots
and you know we could do this with any
number of of outputs of the same type
cool that's all that I've got live time
for questions